so i went skydiving to try to overcome
the fear of heights
but that didn't help did you jump out
yeah yeah jumped out but it was it was a
it was fundamentally different
experience and
i guess there could be a lot of
different flavors of fear of heights
maybe
but the one i have didn't seem to be
connected to
jumping out of a plane it's a very
different because like once you accept
that you're going to jump
then it's it's a different thing i i
think what i'm afraid of
is the moments before it is
is the scariest part absolutely and
i don't think that's emphasized in the
skydiving experience as much
and also just the acceptance of the fact
that it's going to happen
so once you accept it is going to happen
it's not as scary
it's the fact that it's not supposed to
happen and it might
that's the scary part that i i guess i'm
not being eloquent in this
description but there's something about
skydiving that uh was actually
philosophically liberating i was i was
like wow
it it was uh the possibility that you
can walk
on a surface and then at a certain point
there's no surface anymore
to walk on and it's all sudden the world
becomes three-dimensional
and there's this freedom of floating
that the concept of like
of earth disappears for a brief few
seconds i don't know that was
that was wild that was wild but i'm
still terrified of heights so
you